robin can you take us behind the scenes
of your production
um how large was your crew and what kind
of cam like what kind of equipment were
you using for audio and for video
okay um
we used the red camera
for
part of the production
and we had a small crew of um
four people
and what were the four people doing
lighting sound
and um
the camera operator and the camera
operator's assistant
and uh you know then i had uh
you know production assistance hair and
makeup and
what kind of equipment did you have on
like the lighting side and then the
audio side
yeah um
i'm not too much of a technical guy
you know i make sure i have really good
people around me
you know and and i check what they're
using to make sure it's
it presents you know it does a good job
you know and uh i don't often remember
the names of a lot of the items i'm more
of like this works great let's use it
and uh but you know we had the boom mic
lights and
and the camera and uh do you feel like
you could have gone with less crew or
was that like as low as you can go and
then on the other side do you feel like
there were more crew members you really
could have used if if if money or budget
would allow
i would have liked to had tracks
you know and uh or a wheelbarrow
you know
but now i would have liked to maybe had
one or two more people to
help get things done quicker
as far as setting up the
next scene
while we're still shooting this scene
you know because i'm all about um
getting a lot done in a short amount of
time but i also like to spend as much
time possible
getting a scene right
you know but that doesn't take long as
long as
the actors are
comfortable
you know and speaking the of the actual
shoot days i mean how how long were the
shoot days like what what kind of what
was the schedule i mean what was each
individual day and then how long did you
guys shoot overall
every day was different
you know i'm one of these guys that
didn't i don't like
5am
you know
and i'd done a lot of work on films
where you had to be there really early
and then shoot till midnight or
something and i think that if if you
need if that's what has to happen yeah
you have to do it
but a lot of times
i would work it out
where you know
i'd have a start around nine
and run till like 9 10 at night you know
but so that's uh but it's different
every day you know if we didn't if we
only had we had a lot to do
you know i shot it in seven days
so a lot of the work was the hours the
amount of work put into the film was put
in before a camera showed up
i mean we were practicing
blocking at locations
before a camera was ever there so it was
when the camera got there
you know it was just everybody was so
prepared by that it was just like bam
bam bam
so how were you able to be in both
places you say the camera is not there
yet yet you're there yeah i'd find
locations i'd talk to the owners of the
locations
and
rehearse at the locations
before shooting started
i get the actors together
say hey guys
let's all rehearse at this location just
because i come from the theater
and music background you know where we
would rehearse
a lot before we did a show so i
approached this similar to
either way i would a band a rock band
you know we got to rehearse our asses
off before
the crowd shows up the crowd to me was
the camera
you almost make it sound like some of
the locations you were
securing as you were going along in
production so so some of the locations
weren't locked in
beforehand no i was rehearsing on
locations be
i've kind of known
to
get things started before everything's
always there
but
in the pro i've always been able to get
everything there
and done and done well
especially on my on my second film
by you know getting the ball rolling you
know everything's here
you know everything's ready to go
you know so i had to have things we'd be
rehearsing at locations before
official production started i would tell
all the actors and everybody hey
i'm going to make this happen
you know what if it doesn't work we'll
put on a play
you know and for instance that's what
i'm doing right now in los angeles i
have a
play
that was going to be a movie and
it wasn't and so now it's now we were
rehearsing for as a film at the
locations and now i just rewrote it as a
play and we're putting up as a play
you